a big heartfelt congratulations on this
is tremendous
absolutely tremendous people will go
wild for it
thank you
I'm curious at the premiere who are you
sitting directly next to and what did
you say to each other the moment the
film ended
up [ __ ] yeah yeah so
when I do
so no spoilers for you then
well I think I know everything yeah and
I definitely heard a lot from people who
were in the room and were moved by it I
mean the people the people I was with
before the film and after had been
changed they transformed by the by the
experience of the film so I could tell
that it was extremely moving and they
expressed as much and I was very very
happy to hear that
that's phenomenal
um one of the things I love seeing uh in
these films is you interacting with
Angela Bassett right like she always
radiates strength she and she's a queen
for goodness sakes in these films what
is it like to actually be there on set
with her are you ever in a moment where
she doesn't take and you just kind of
like
stop yourself like yo that was that was
incredible
well you know when you're in a scene
with Angela Bassett you have to come
correct you know yeah it's into I I I
feel intimidated every time
um but she's such a giving actress so
she really doesn't have heirs about her
I mean as the queen she assumes that she
assumes The Heirs of the person she's
playing but she's really just uh an
incredibly gracious and and and generous
actress so I'm I I don't want to drop
the ball when I'm in the scene with
Angela Bassett so I'm minding my own
business and trying to bring myself my
full self to it so that I am I'm that
I'm worthy of her of being in the same
scene with her
you know you mentioned just a second ago
when we were talking about people's
reactions to the movie about people
being transformed after they've seen it
but people watch these movies in so many
different ways and there are nerds like
me too that love all the little details
about how they relate to the comics or
even the details about the way things
look and the way costumes look what is
your favorite type of reaction from a
Marvel fan when they have finished
watching one of these movies
I think I I really love how observant
Marvel fans can be and oftentimes they
notice things that even I didn't notice
and I love that I love to be surprised
by a detail that I missed
um because of how much of a fanatic they
are
um with with the comics and with all
that there's there's so much detail and
every single creative person is coming
with a well of research that they're
bringing to this like Hannah beakler the
set designer she is
at confounding how detailed she gets
with why she's doing what she's doing in
fact she was my first stop when I got to
Atlanta to get ready for this I went to
Hannah because I was like I want to know
uh what is inspiring you and I learned
so much from talking to her and looking
at her research packet it was incredible
now another thing that we're excited for
you for is uh playing another
superheroic role coming up soon which is
of course Patricia Trevor Noah's mom in
that film when can we expect to see this
is there anything you can tell us about
um about this film about uh your prep
for it and when we can see it yo man I
don't know I let me tell you that the
making of any film is a miracle
this is a miracle that films get made
and get seen like that they get to the
point that they get seen
um what I was saying is that uh my love
for that story has not died but you have
to be so painstaking in how you put a
team together because it's it's all
about the strength of the team you put
together and you know that it
that is just proof positive of Ryan
coogler's incredible leadership in this
film because he's so he's very very
mindful about who he puts together and
because of the quality of artists that
he has collaborated with behind the
camera is why this film is what it is so
that's the kind of level of detail that
I
um I'm looking for for uh for Trevor
Noah's a story and uh it will be when it
will be and I hope that is soon right on
us too hey thank you so much for the
time congratulations thank you